i'm here at the wired party taking a
break from the CES show floor pretty
much everything that we've seen so far
this year is what we expected to see
something it was a little bit unexpected
is that we anticipated there were going
to be more android phones and tablets
shipping with the new version of android
that just came out called ice cream
sandwich well there are a lot of phones
and tablets we're running android most
of them are running the older versions
and the people that have been showing
them to us have told us that they're
going to update the new phones and
tablets with ice cream sandwich in the
coming months so that was a little bit
unexpected the other thing that I've
seen that I've been really impressed
with are all of the cameras and all the
action in all the different camera
categories from point2 shoots to smaller
body cameras with interchangeable lenses
to brand-new DSLRs seen some really
exciting stuff from all the big names
like Nikon and Canon and fujifilm and
we're really hoping to see those cameras
come out soon because it looks like
they're going to be really big hit with
consumers I suppose there's also some
buzz around Windows Phone and Windows 8
tablets but from what we've seen there's
not a whole lot but the devices we have
seen are pretty strong even so they're
not going to come out for a few more
months so we're going to sort of weight
to pass judgment on that but there is a
lot of buzz around windows on mobiles
which is a big change over previous
years so that's my take and if you'll
excuse me I gotta go back to work
you